[Música]
[Aplausos]
y más
[Música]
te pasó alguna vez de estar sentado con
conversando con un empresario o quizás
escuchando
una conferencia de puede ser y tener una
pregunta atravesada en tu interior y
decir cómo es que esta persona pudo
hacer esto y cuando digo pudo hacer esto
es construir semejante empresa o de
repente es operar en una argentina como
la que conocemos no llena de
incertidumbre volatibilidad
y lo loco es que
le digo que es loco para mí que con el
correr del tiempo en los últimos años
quizás a raíz del crecimiento de nuestra
empresa es una pregunta con la que me
encuentro y sebastián como consiguieron
ustedes hacer esto como posicionaron una
marca de esta manera en tan poco tiempo
como es que cuatro mil emprendedores
logras que cuatro mil emprendedores se
pongan la camiseta y trabajen bajo la
misma marca en el sector inmobiliario
y
la pregunta me ha llevado a buscar
buscar adentro y decir para que déjame
pensar y la respuesta con la que vuelvo
es la receta es dar
y la respuesta está despierta en la cara
que puedo observar la gente que converso
me dicen dar que tiene que ver dar con
montar una empresa que tiene que ver dar
en el sector ismo en el sector
inmobiliario o en el sector empresarial
y dar cuando pienso y cuando digo dar me
refiero servir pensar en el otro agregar
valor y quizás tiene que ver porque yo
accidentalmente me convertí en
empresario y de eso tiene que ver lo que
viene a compartir hoy con ustedes
al igual que tantas otras cosas dar uno
lo aprende inconscientemente quizás
desde una edad muy temprana y eso fue lo
que ocurrió conmigo creo que antes de
aprender a leer y escribir quizás a un
inconsciente de que estaba aprendiendo a
dar lo empecé a observar tengo el
privilegio de nacer en un hogar especial
distinto quizás
mi padre es uno de esos médicos en
extinción
un loco siempre traía la historia de sus
pacientes a casa era como que estaban
ahí con nosotros mi madre entregada
siempre ayudando involucrada en la
iglesia trabajando con jóvenes con
adolescentes era como que los socios
siempre buscaban a quien ayudar y así
fue que lo fui aprendiendo inconsciente
inconscientemente y no existe y se va y
cuando fue el cual el recuerdo el primer
recuerdo que vos tenés de dar para mí
fue un día que íbamos a la escuela
íbamos a la escuela y pasado por una
plaza y en lo lejos vimos a un borracho
cuando salimos de la escuela mi hermano
mi hermana y yo la legión papá podemos
pasar para ver si lo encontramos y ese
señor se llamaba ramón
y lo buscábamos a ramón lo buscamos a
ramón y así fue que trajimos a ramón a
casa y yo lo pensaba estos días y yo
digo que lo que trae un borracho casa lo
trajimos a la cochera casa y ramón se
convirtió en una suerte de huésped
temporal de la familia sosa puedo hasta
aún siendo un niño recordar el dolor de
ramón y ramón lo afeita amos que crecía
la barba y lo lavamos y lo cuidamos le
dábamos a comer y cuando ramón a vecinos
llegaba la noche casa lo salíamos a
buscar para ver si ramón estaba bien y
así que uno aprende a dar y pronto se
convierte en una extensión tú bien parte
de tu cuerpo y lo hace si lo haces con
pasión lo loco de dar es que lo que no
sabemos es que dar tiene un impacto muy
grande pero no solamente la persona que
recibe sino la persona que está dando
también así que este dar que era como un
miembro más de la familia se sentaba con
nosotros a la mesa nos llegó por toda la
ciudad por el barrio por la ciudad por
la provincia y un día terminamos en
minsk bielorrusia
pequeña república en la ex unión
soviética donde llegamos con la idea de
hacer algunas cosas y terminamos
haciendo un montón entre ellas ayudando
a las víctimas de la catástrofe de
chernóbil
hoy no hace falta hablar mucho de
chernóbil porque esta serie lo ha hecho
bastante famoso así que sabemos todo lo
que estamos hablando este auto que
ustedes ven acá lleno de cosas estábamos
en suiza estábamos regresando a minsk
ahora la locura de dar no solamente
quiere de los socios sino de un montón
de amigos y conocidos y familias en
suiza en alemania en finlandia
habíamos tejido una red una red que
colaboraba en esta causa de edad y era
una generaba curiosidad una par de locos
argentinos allá en la ex unión soviética
mientras estábamos quizás acostumbrados
a recibir la ayuda acá estábamos del
otro lado del charco allá brindando
ayuda y en el medio de todo esto
era muy lindo tenía que hacer algo que
hacemos los adolescentes que es estudiar
y amigo me decisivos como hacía para
estudiar con el ruso sabías ruso y como
no teníamos una limitación el idioma
tenía que estudiar en casa mamá era como
la decana de la familia y en este
pequeño departamento en el que vivíamos
nos hacía estudiar y esa parte quizás no
era del todo fácil porque todo
adolescente que lo que quiere y quiere
escuchar el ruido de la campana en el
recreo quiere salir y hacer las
travesuras que todos hacemos y qué
queremos hacer yo no tuve eso en algún
punto mi mujer dice que quizás nunca
termine de ser del todo les cnte no y
pasó el tiempo terminé mis estudios y
estaba la verdad que pasándola bien
porque tenía amigos porque ahora hablaba
mejor el idioma me podía entender y
estábamos involucrados un montón de
cosas y con el correr del tiempo recibía
cartas cada tanto no había whatsapp no
había skype no había zoom todo era
alguien no sé si seguimos yendo el
correo íbamos al correo y recibimos las
cartas que quizá vienen durar un montón
de semanas en llegar y la habríamos con
alegría con entusiasmo con emoción y
podía ver leyendo las cartas que mis
amigos me contaban cómo su vida avanzaba
algunos ya tenían trabajo otros en la
universidad y de pronto se apoderó de mí
esta cuestión de chivas se te está
escapando la vida 19 años tenía pues yo
sentía que necesitaba también avanzar no
se sentía que tenía que prepararme
estudiar profesionalizar medios estaba
convencido que quería seguir dando
representando a mi país ayudando
colaborando pero para eso tenía que
estudiar y ocurrió algo loco
en el medio toda esta locura porque
vieron que yo les decía que dar genera
un impacto en los hombres en aquella
persona que recibe sino la persona que
da estábamos en una clínica trabajando
con un grupo de médicos norteamericanos
y al terminar esa par de semanas una de
las personas de aaron se acerca y me
dice se va quisiera sentarme a charlar
con tus padres y quisiera aunque
quisiera decirles así que nos sentamos
en la cocina en casa nuestro
departamento pequeño y chiquito la mesa
y los 4000 se puede traducir la lo edit
me dice estoy sorprendido del trabajo
que usted están haciendo de la entrega
que ustedes tienen de todo lo que hace
todo lo que dan me gustaría invitar a
este joven que está acá que venga eeuu
yo puede encargar de cubrir todos los
estudios que vaya a la universidad que
él quiera yo no sé si mi inglés es
bastante básico yo estar entendiendo
bien pero se estaba abriendo delante mío
una puerta y lo que estaba descubriendo
es que esto personal yo sin esperar
absolutamente nada a cambio por lo que
mis padres habían dado yo estaba ahora
cosechan porque dar abre la puerta para
recibir y así es que llegó a eeuu mis 20
años llegó y lo que yo quería era
estudiar rápido porque tenía un mundo
que conquistar quería representar a mi
país quería seguir dando quería seguir
preparándome y llegué eeuu sabía que va
a ser difícil a otro idioma otra cultura
lo que había olvidado es que ni van a
estar mis padres y mi hermano ni mi
hermana para bancarme su día que todos
tenemos que te cuesta cuando te estás
hablando nuevo lugar
con el objetivo y con la visión y con
este cuadro tan fuerte puesto delante de
mí me propuse estudiar en tiempo récord
saqué las mejores notas fui reconocido y
se abre otra oportunidad de conseguir y
sacar un máster becado llegó a otra
universidad donde conozco a una española
norteamericana y pude darme cuenta
manera rápido que iba a compartir el
resto de mi vida con esta mujer tremenda
mujer otra gran fanática de edad y me
acuerdo que así como soy yo que no le
gusta perder tiempo
le dije dot y mira que yo vuelvo a mi
país yo tengo un sueño tengo esto y eso
seguramente que ahora pensó aquí se cree
este pibe nos acabamos de conocer
pero se ve que en algún lado algo la
atrapó y la locura de este cordobés se
transformó en la locura de dos así que
nos casamos y empezamos y buscábamos el
pasaje buscamos la conexión buscamos el
puente con argentina mientras buscábamos
conozco una amiga de ella y me hiciste
porque no venían a trabajar conmigo a
donde yo trabajo en bienes raíces y
bienes raíces que tiene que ver con
argentina el área pregunta que hice yo
pero dije por esta que estábamos
mientras tanto arranquemos así que por
primera vez en mi vida a mis 26 años
trabajo por un cheque algo totalmente
desconocido nunca había trabajado en el
sector privado un mundo todo nuevo
pero empiezo a trabajar y me di cuenta
que era bastante parecido a lo que
habíamos hecho anteriormente con mis
padres la única diferencia que debe de
estar ayudando ahora a niños oa madres o
padres en una clínica en una iglesia o
en una escuela ahora era ayudar a dar a
una pareja una familia que estaba
buscando una hogar era estar en un
momento especial de una persona en un
momento que puede ser estresante podría
estar ahí brindando un consejo sincero
brindando a veces una escucha a un oído
y de pronto ocurrió algo mágico
nuevamente no sé si alguna vez te pasó
de que vos ves lo que va a ocurrir y lo
ves tan claro de manera cristalina me
acuerdo el día el momento de la
conversación la mirada cómplice
entre mi socia y yo
nos miramos y dijimos ahora entiendo la
conexión ahora entiendo lo que vamos a
hacer vamos a llevar esta idea y este
concepto lo vamos a llevar a argentina
donde donde un montón de otras personas
y jóvenes cientos o miles quizás como
vos se puedan desarrollar y puedan
crecer y puedan brindar un servicio
quizás diferente así que
agarramos y metimos todas nuestras cosas
en una maleta y llegamos a argentina y
llegamos con esa ilusión esa utopía y
esas ganas de hacer y durante 5 años
lo único que hicimos fue trabajar
trabajar trabajar vimos como todos
nuestros ahorros se fueron vimos como
todo lo que teníamos y lo que no
teníamos lo pusimos en el proyecto
dejamos acumular deudas y la frustración
de sentir que cuando te paras y haces un
balance o decís a ver cómo nos fue
es decir no me cierra por ningún lado y
ahí te vienen una marea de emociones y
preguntas que será que nací yo para ser
empresario será que yo puedo llevar este
barco a destino será que este proyecto
calza o entra dentro de la argentina
y recuerdo que me tomo un tiempo me tomó
tiempo para alejarme y pensar y mientras
que me tomo ese espacio mi hermano mi
hermano menor fe si se enferman o tienen
que operar
mi hermano entre el quirófano el cuando
sale del quirófano el escenario este
tumor era mucho más complejo y difícil
de lo que imaginábamos a los pocos días
vuelve a entrar al quirófano y cuando
sale las noticias aún peor
y ahí comenzaba lo que iba a ser una
aventura de casi cinco años donde mi
hermano iba a entrar y salir del
quirófano más de 30 veces
pero lo que yo vi a lo largo de estos
cinco años en mi hermano fue tremendo y
fue la oportunidad que tuve de vivir y
ver y reconectar con el sueño que nos
había traído argentina se encuentra mi
hermano tenía una capacidad de que cada
vez que bolt iba a saber la pregunta era
cómo estás voz el puede ser una cama
enchufada un montón de cosas y él te
decía cómo estás vos cómo está el
proyecto sabía cada detalle y sabiendo
que estaba ocurriendo para que usted
tiene una idea de la clase de persona y
lo que me enseñó recuerdo la última
operación con mi mano le transfirieron
le trasplantaron ocho órganos y estaba
yo al lado de él cuando estaban
preparando para llevarlo al quirófano y
mi hermano
hermano se llama y me dice che se
iniciaba entonces me acerco y yo estaba
totalmente temblaba todo estaba con un
pánico total y yo lo peleen en su eje
centrado tranquilo y me dice venir y me
acercó y me dice el oído comprar
empanadas a todas las enfermeras y yo lo
miro y le digo si fede no lo podía creer
y me vuelve a sé que me sé pero no te
olvides
y se lo llevan y yo si este pibe no
puede ser ese fue mi hermano que me
recordó que mi hijo se trata de dar se
trata de pensar en el otro se trata de
ayudar
y se fue se metió en las cirugías de
veintipico de horas
recuerdo cuando despertó dije no compre
las empanadas
y la tenacidad la perseverancia el
sentido del humor que tenía me recordó y
me dijo me ayudó a volver al proyecto me
ayudó a conectar con el propósito y el
motivo el con esta emoción y saben que
otra cosa no ayudarme en cuenta que esos
cinco años el foco no había estado
puesto en lo que yo he aprendido de
chico el foco de estado puesto en
nuestros objetivos el foco de estado
puesto en lograr las metas que teníamos
que lograr me había dejado llevar por la
presión de casa matriz de llegaría a
abrir la cantidad de oficina que
queríamos abrir que había sido egoísta y
repasando estos días y pensando en esto
me di cuenta de cuánto aún de espacio de
mejora tengo
así que volví y volví renovado y metimos
y penetró y ese dar y ése servir penetró
en la identidad de la compañía y hoy con
el crecimiento de la empresa cada vez es
más difícil pero lo hago una prioridad
de que cada persona que se suma y se
incorpora entienda para qué hacemos lo
que hacemos cómo nació esta compañía
cuál es nuestra pasión busco cada
oportunidad de recordar y de sembrar
estos principios estos valores que
aprendí mientras que cuidaba ramón
mientras mientra que trabajaba y ayudaba
a los niños en bielorrusia encuentro
mucho paralelismo entre la red que
buscamos solidaria construir acá entre
todos los emprendedores con la red que
bien mi padre tejer en la xxi nos evite
que en europa donde buscábamos ayuda
quizás quizás aún con todos los espacios
de mejora que tenemos tanto en la
empresa como en mi vida yo creo que el
dar que la ayudar que el servir es
probablemente el factor más importante
por cual porque esta empresa se ha
convertido en un referente una empresa
líder no solamente en argentina sino que
en la región pero a una de las cosas que
creo que más me alegra y más me llena de
todo esto quizás no son los valores de
sebastián o de fere o de dot y
sino que son los valores de muchas
personas que trabajan dentro de este
proyecto
que buscamos y velamos por estos valores
tales así que están escritos las
murallas en las paredes de muchos de
nuestros locales
yo creo y pienso
que si cuatro mil emprendedores
pudieron engancharse en esta locura de
dar de dos personas y encontraron un
lugar donde crecer prosperar proyectarse
y brindar un servicio fresco diferente
qué país y qué mundo podríamos construir
si todos diéramos de nosotros un poquito
más muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
ah
[Música]